Separating the data and control plane can allow
for independent evolution of the data and control plane.
Separating vendor hardware from the logic that controls
the behavior of the network, and the potential to
more easily reason about network behavior since the
behavior is now controlled from a single logically-centralized control
program. While it's possible that separating the control
plane from the data plane Could result in architectures
that are more fault tolerant or more scalable.
The separation of data and control plain does not
inherently make the network more fault tolerant or more
scalable. Therefore, neither of the first two options apply.